if the call of duty franchise is a
well-oiled machine black ops 3 is the
replacement part that keeps the wheels
moving for yet another year the newest
iteration of Call of Duty multiplayer
begins on a promising note as black ops
three specialists cover the screen you
still have the traditional loadout
system with weapons items and equipment
but specialists also provide a new power
weapon or power ability but there's too
much time between specialist unlocks to
keep things moving along and when I'm
not learning the intricacies of a new
character black ops 3 defaults to a more
generic call of duty experience then
there's black ops 3 s new zombies map
shadows of evil it's fantastic the
difficulty is high but zombies now more
than ever is a learning experience and
seeing the tangible result of your
practice with co-op partners is
rewarding when it comes to the campaign
black ops 3 is a chore it's a boring
crawl that wastes no time throwing you
into its routine and its undead modes
and the first 10 hours of multiplayer
black ops 3 excels but in its campaign
and merely crawls forward black ops 3
doesn't offer anything remarkable to
this series it does just enough to
maintain the call of duty status quo the
franchise however slowly continues its
steady march